thank you thank you thank you and happy
st. Patrick's Day
thank you very much did you already
drink yourself sick
so it's unnecessary now that we have a
president who makes you want to puke all
the time yeah the the White House look
great a bad first day by splashing green
energy and everything else that's good
in the budget did you see the budget oh
yes it takes all of them they put out
their new budget the Trump bus it takes
away all the money from scientists and
teachers and human rights workers and
meals on wheels and Muppets and gives it
to the people who really needed the
defense contractors if only there was a
way to get the f-35 to run on coal it
would be a perfect but halt hey we're
going to put the coal miners back to
work that's what truck that's what he
goes around the country saying every day
we're going to put the gold but that's
what passes for good news in this
administration you going back down in
that toxic hole
and as they're lowering the mint and
then we're going to take away your
healthcare this week this week we
finally found out what Trump care is you
know the whole campaign he was something
terrific remember I'm going to replace
it with something to Ricky he with
there's so many close to him saying it's
going to everyone's going to be covered
everybody's going to cost you a fraction
a fraction a fraction with the old ones
and better coverage wow that is quite a
deal everybody fraction better coverage
people are going to want to get sick
this plan is so good you are going to
wish you had a tumor just so you can go
to the hospital under my plan now we see
what the plan surprise 24 million people
lose health coverage and the rich get a
giant giant tax cut this is the new
place we're living in in America meals
on wheels the new budget director said
not showing any results you mean other
than not killing cripples and veterans
and older people old people you know
3,200 jobs at the EPA are going to be
cut under this new budget remember
during the campaign Trump is always
saying what do you have to lose this
stuff life as we know
[Music]
the budget director also said about the
new budget that the after-school meals
program
gone you know I've always said this you
want Republicans to care about kids
you're going to just have to jam them
back in the uterus
climate change research but for years
they said well you know climate change
needs more study not zero they made a
point $0.00 in research for climate
change the greatest challenge of our
time and they're like nothing now this
is like if your car was breaking down
and your solution was put black tape
over the check engine light cutting PBS
out I mean most people look at Sesame
Street and they see a show that educates
children Trump sees a show where a
landlord is being forced to rent to
black people and I'm not just the policy
part of our national nightmare that we
are living through every week you know
there's two parts of this policy and
then personality personality because
ours after our last show a couple of
weeks ago president crazypants started
tweeting about how Obama tapped his
phone at Trump Tower based on nothing
nothing that's the great thing about
having tiny hands it's easier to pull
stuff right out of your ass
[Applause]
and even though Obama himself has said
this is [ __ ] the wiretapping and our
former national intelligence director
said that the FBI director said that
Speaker of the House said that the
chairman of the House Senate
Intelligence Committee and the Senate
from both sides of the aisle said this
Trump addressed all these doubters today
he said well I saw someone say it on Fox
News really that's what I saw someone
saying it on Fox News what what has to
happen before Republic what has to
happen Republican Patriots before you
act does the president have to get naked
roll around on the White House lawn
start eating the grass and going
linndrum I'm a lawn mower
[Applause]
I'm going to have a heart attack before
this piece and Trump said this today in
front of Angela Merkel did you see that
she had a look on her face like how I
long for the days when I got creepy
shoulder rubs from George W Bush and
then oh that was a great meeting with
Angela Merkel he obviously hates her and
of course he's so good at hiding this
stuff they were sitting there and the
people of shouting does you want to
shake hands like every president has
ever done in every photo shop you know
no even [ __ ] her no I'm not going to
kick your ass and then after the meeting
you know he tweeted lousy meeting with
German Chancellor Barney Rubble
low-energy unattractive didn't even want
to make me pop a tic tac
[Applause]
don't start groaning uncle [ __ ] nuts
on you today you can see I am right on
the edge here do not [ __ ] push me
we're supposed to be on the same team no
this is driving look at me driving us
all crazy right please tell me about
this piece I mean this is the craziest
Administration ever they think the
microwave oven is filming them
but during press conferences they don't
seem to realize that being broadcast on
TV and I saw it on Fox's but by the
president's own admission all he does
all day is watch cable news which is
nothing but commercials for zoloft paxil
celexa abilify Don pick one
[Applause]